to start with let's shoot this piece
are you guys ready yeah yeah yeah okay
let's shoot this piece of let's do
it all right
you wanted that to be in it that was us
that was it that was us acting out of
control isn't it hi I'm Harrison Ford
and we are the cast of Indiana Jones and
the um
Dial Dial of Destiny we're going to take
a buzzfeed trivia trivia
hey hi I'm Harrison Ford and this is
Phoebe Warner Bridge Boyd o'brook Sean
at Renee Wilson Mass Migos got a few
questions here a buzzfeed trivia
test
first in Raiders of the Lost Ark when
Indiana Jones takes the idol at the
beginning of the movie what does he try
and replace it with
while Indiana is afraid of snakes what
is his dad Henry Jones terrified of
birds spiders rats or snakes as well
it's Birds it's rats well are you sure
if you're not running in with the
umbrella with the birds doesn't it
all right on three birds isn't it
rats
which of these characters does not
appear in Temple of Doom Kate Capshaw is
Willie Scott
as Short Round Amish Puri as molaram or
John Rhys Davies as solid which one is
not in Temple of Doom okay young man
John Reese that's your favorite one you
better be right he's right John Reese
Davies yes
you got it right okay that's one for you
one for you what I thought we got Birds
tiny elephant in the beginning which you
get 10 points for this is too hard in
the Last Crusade while trying to make it
to the Holy Grail Indie must spell what
word as one of the tests
Jehovah holy penitent or knife is it
Jehovah Jehovah yes for a thousand yeah
yes yeah all right I I say Jehovah that
was mass
in Kingdom of the Crystal Skull when
India reaches a nuclear test Town what
does he hide in to escape the blast a
refrigerator a garage a trunk of a car
or a child's Playhouse well I remember
but fridge refrigerator refrigerator
yeah obviously your refrigerator I'm
going to say A Child's Place
the Raiders of the Lost Ark Indy visits
Marion in Nepal to retrieve what
artifact a crucifix owned by Coronado
the headpiece of the staff of raw a
journal which details where the ark is
or shankara stone isn't it the headpiece
is part of the film are we looking for
the ark here guys yeah that's a little
too obviously it has all the details
there's no answer here what do you think
it is I don't know
[Laughter]
in the Last Crusade while in the library
in these spots various numbers that
indicate where the tomb is what are the
three numbers are they four five six two
eight nine
comparison's phone number he's giving
you
7 10. 5 7 12.
I remember that being a seven
there's always a seven so either C or D
yeah three seven ten or five seven
twelve Eric those people try at three
seven ten they're going up before
okay let's see if you're right oh my God
three seven
and finally in dial of Destiny what is
Indy's nickname for Helena piglet
piglet I remember
acting ever a few times no talking about
yours talking about me
piglet or what's clear and obvious oh
I'm bad
so cute now my question is what sound
does a wombat make yeah
I got seven out of eight that means I'm
one of the biggest Indiana Jones fans
around I'm eight out of eight how do you
get seven of y'all
I got two I can't believe I got the job
no I'm not gonna and I still lost what
what you know
we are very excited to be yeah there's a
movie coming selling this yeah in a
couple days we're here to sell dial of
Destiny and we're gonna fail unless you
go to the movie
thank you
foreign
[Music]